let's hear from the most important
people in the world for the David Pacman
show it is our audience we take calls
occasionally via Discord you can find
our Discord at davidpakman.com
Discord and we're going to start today
with a very important person Mr Rogers
in Atlanta Georgia Mr Rogers welcome
what's on your mind today
hey uh Dave welcome to my neighborhood
um just wanted to ask
um I'm having difficulty I I guess you'd
say uh reaching out to members would say
across the aisle about the Herschel
Walker and uh Warner Brock campaign okay
um I have a lot of neighbors that just
want to vote for vote for Herschel
because he was a damn good dog and uh I
mean as a native Georgian I understand
that and I get that but I'm like
try to talk to these guys about how you
know he's definitely not a good uh
representation of what it means to be a
Georgian or Southern Belle these days
and so let's help me understand that and
this is interesting because you're
you're talking to these folks Herschel
Walker is completely unable to explain
his position on even a single issue how
do these people that like him do do they
not even care what his positions are do
they pretend like they understand what
his positions are what how do they
explain his incoherence
um I mean I try to say like you know I
appreciate his time in football but his
tte just not what we need yeah
um when it comes to his positions
um they say you know it doesn't matter
you know he's just Republican he's just
gonna vote Republican I'm like y'all
y'all worried about uh uh Warnock being
a Biden boy and I'm like he's gonna as
soon as Walker gets there he's just
gonna be uh I don't know Moscow Mitch
Suburban he's not gonna do anything for
majority he's just gonna be told to vote
and how to vote yeah I mean it's all
obvious whenever you you uh you see his
um what he called news conferences that
Walker is about as coach as you can get
on some of his background kind of yeah
and still incoherent have you heard from
any folks about the reaction now to the
whole abortion Scandal do do they care
about this story or are they calling it
fake news or they don't care
um I have one guy talked on a regular he
says it's fake news oh he just doesn't
believe yeah
uh another guy says you know he says
it's taken to court so we'll see how the
dollars fly and I think at least you're
willing to listen to the court
and I haven't had much time to uh talk
to that's really depressing yeah let me
ask you this are some of these folks who
support Walker are they otherwise normal
moderately intelligent people or are
there people who if you probed their
beliefs on just about everything are a
little bit wacky
um I'd say it's a mix of both because
you know you'd go down to the the bar
for a football game during commercials
you talk to people we'll talk normal
stuff but then all sudden but yeah it
can get a little odd sometimes but yeah
I'll be honest it seems like most of the
time Georgia fans just want to vote for
Herschel because he was a damn good dog
okay and what what do you mean a damn
good dog
oh I'm sorry David uh the college
football thing down here in the
southeast United States uh damn good dog
is a Georgia saying for any good uh
particularly good football player Oh but
I'm so from I'm a damn good dog I'm a
graduate of the University of Georgia
myself but uh you get the damn good dog
uh I guess title if you really show how
just how good you are all right very
good is that a bike chain I hear in the
background
yeah I apologize for that my windows are
open it's a nice day today is that
January did I pick it it actually is a
bike chain
yeah oh wow hardly going back all right
that's it oh oh oh I okay I thought it
was like a bite all right very good all
right Mr Rogers thank you let's let's
hope Warnock wins you know let's let's
hope
indeed thank you all right thank you
very much for the call there's Mr Rogers
in Atlanta making a number of very very
important declarations there one of our
sponsors today is Bluetooth a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form and at a fraction of
the cost and they're giving my audience
an entire month's supply for free so if
you think you could benefit from an
extra boost of confidence when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video the will give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping